[Music]
you know we're better together
so the meaning in Arabic means like
let's go kind of it's kind of calling
people to get up and celebrate
enjoy so that's like the general meaning
of the words
[Music]
me I
write
I definitely feel like I have a mission
and it's not an easy one although I'm
getting a lot of support much more than
I ever thought I was going to get
but it's still a mission I'm still doing
something that's different
I'm still opening a new door but just
being that initiator for other women
it makes it worth it I'm happy to be
that person for other women I'm happy
when I get videos from little girls
um singing my song you know it just
gives me goosebumps it makes me very
happy because I feel like growing up I
needed that and I'm happy to be that for
someone else
[Applause]